let's face it this is the one you were
waiting for what I saw if it wasn't it
should be its what another trailer that
was shown at comic-con was the trailer
to Deadpool and like every other further
that was shown at comic-con ever it was
leaked online bootleg version of it
unlike the other ones they didn't
release it they didn't roll with it in
there whatever has been bootleg here
here's the high-def version no Fox is
holding out man they're like not yet I
guess we can get one in three weeks I
don't know if it's gonna be the same as
this or different I look different
because I'm talking about this one now
and I just don't want to repeat myself
in three weeks what is this Deadpool
trailer looks really really good funny
things Deadpool is like a comic-con
thing at this point because last year
after comic-con that test footage leaked
online leaked on live which is pretty
much the studio going all right we'll
leak it and we'll see if the fans love
it we all loved it so now it's a movie
and the scene that was the Deadpool test
footage is actually in this trailer so
it's in the movie historians Wade Wilson
has cancer so this ominous dude comes to
him he's like we can make you better we
can make you a superhero so he has this
procedure done and it becomes Deadpool
but you see all the meta humor in this
trailer that you wanted in a Deadpool
movie you're like oh my god they're
doing it perfectly like when the guys
like we're gonna make you a superhero
he's like just make sure the super suit
isn't green or animated
that's really funny che I love a
gratuitous amount of meta humor and this
looks to have him and the action looks
kick-ass to Deadpool's got some
straight-up moves like this scene where
he whips around he shoots his gun the
bullet goes through three dudes
simultaneously after he gets all these
dudes asses he's like boom like suck it
and he just goods nailed by
Colossus from the x-men totally caught
me off guard I had no idea they're gonna
start crossing roads and Africa's
plowed by Colossus he stands up he's
like you big chrome block this is a
girl with him and he's like so what's
your name she's like negasonic teenage
warhead he's like mega so what the
is the coolest name ever accused the
music to the camera and then music comes
on and a bunch more kick-ass ray
greatest Stan Lee cameo ever though if
you haven't seen the trailer I don't
want to ruin if I feel like that's
something you would take out of the
trailer so you want to save it for the
movie but greatest Stan Lee cameo ever
really it is I love the catchphrase in
the trailer - with great power comes
great irresponsibility it's just too
good to not have ultimately this trailer
proves that the abomination that was
Deadpool in the abomination that was the
x-men origins Wolverine movie was
terrible but it wasn't Ryan Reynolds
fault everyone
at the time that he was a good pick for
Deadpool if they did Deadpool at all in
there I'm really glad Ryan Reynolds is
getting a mulligan for this role and I'm
glad that he is showing the heat is
perfect for the role of that dialogue at
the end though where I believe it's got
to be his friend right we're talking
shift to something like that you feel
like it's two dudes friends cuz
Deadpool's face is all messed up you see
zebras like you are hard to
look at you look like Freddy Krueger
a topographical map of Utah was
that funny I lost my to that when I
was like good good job trailer oh just
this just dawned on me just now they're
gonna come out with a trail their cell
they're gonna be a green band trailer
this trailer was a red band trailer and
they had the shit's the the damn
it's the blood it was great whatever
trailer you see online or in the movie
theater it's gonna be a green band
trailer here's the open for a red band
trailer guys in the end Deadpool is
looking like it's the perfect Deadpool
movie that you want I want more of that
meta humor I want him to fight someone
he just takes the boom mic from offstage
and starts beating someone with it I
have high hopes for this one man if you
weren't a Deadpool fan before you'll
watch this trailer and you're like yeah
that's the cool character I can see what
all the fuss is about the comic-con
Deadpool trailer from Hull H or bootleg
or wherever you watched it have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you